we got will here will what's up man
hey guys how's it going happy friday
happy friday to you as well let's get
two things out of the way first one
breaking news you dropped out
i'm taking a semester break
[Laughter]
walk us through the decision to decide
to take a semester break
yeah i just think um you know q4 is
going to be pretty wild and the
opportunity cost of you know not having
like my full attention on this space is
uh i don't know too great or at least
over the next couple months so
just gonna kind of give bitcoin my full
focus for the next you know
two three months and see how it goes but
uh yeah for now for now it's just uh i'm
taking a semester off i love it i love
it uh i think this is a good idea so uh
we're excited that you're doing it
second question we are uh two weeks into
you being at college how drunk has
everyone been give us a college update
real quick
oh well
i mean
[Laughter]
the first week was so this week so that
that's like a 10. like i got a couple
buddies that ended up in the hospital
but
um
i'm i'm i'm not getting getting too
crazy but yeah there's there's some
people wilding out
well did you just
did you just hit us with a casual my
friends went to the hospital and that's
a 10.
yeah people people wilding out the first
week i don't know people just
i guess like everybody wants to throw
crazy parties and then like so everyone
comes to their party so it's like
yeah first week i mean it's been like
that the last three years but yeah it's
pretty wild
oh my bad you're shell-shocked you're
like in the fog of war all right let's
get into bitcoin uh let's start off with
um these price clusters the u2 xo uh
realized price distribution explain what
this is and we're gonna pull up the
chart here uh to show people but what
what exactly is this and then how do you
analyze it
yeah so it's basically just on chain
volume so you're looking at you know
different price levels in which how much
bitcoin supply is moved at um and so
what you see is we kind of have these
four very distinct volume clusters we
kind of have this pre bull market
cluster which is about 28 and a half
percent of supply uh and that's between
like called 3k 11k um and then the one
below us
while we range for two three months um
and that's right between 30 and 40k and
that's about 15 and a half percent of
supply um the one we're currently in
called between uh 45 50k uh that's about
9.6 percent of supply and then we
finally have one um smaller cluster kind
of in that distribution range that we
were in uh in kind of march april that's
about seven percent of supply between
54k and call it 60k
got it and then when you look at the
state of profitability uh by the way the
charts that you've been putting out now
are very very clear so you're doing a
great job in terms of highlighting with
the colors and stuff i like it uh let's
look at the adjusted sopra um and kind
of explain to us what's happening here
with this reversal
yeah good old friend sober um he's
looking good so like you know one thing
that we have been watching for like two
months ago was we wanted to see sober
break above one which is the threshold
for um you know is the market trading in
a state of profit or loss and then we
wanted to see us you know see the see
the metric come back and retest one a
support on a price correction and then
us and then see it consolidate above one
um and kind of stabilize to get that
confirmation that we're in this uh
uptrend and so what we you know we had
that retest of one as support we
consolidated above one um and so far
it's it's held so you know that that to
me is confirming that the the broader
trend is bullish um one thing to note
though um you know it's given that we
haven't had a retest of one in over a
month
it's not crazy to suspect like that we
might um but when you go back and look
at the end of last year i mean we went
two or three months without having a
full reset but you know just keep that
in mind at some point we will come back
down and retest that one threshold
got it and then let's walk through the
supply dynamics um it seems like this is
very very bullish and you know a
continuation of setting up this like
supply shock but walk us through things
maybe starting with this liquid supply
rsi
yeah i mean like the supply side i mean
it's like undeniably bullish um i don't
know like it's hard to find um other
setups i mean i guess you could say like
late last year but you know it's looking
very very clear-cut to be honest
um this liquid supply rsi i created like
two or three months ago it's basically
it's a 365 um stock rsi using like the
30-day change of a liquid supply so
in essence it's just trying to capture
the broader movement of you know
a liquid supply and so it's basically
trying to identify these supply shocks
like broader macro supply shocks um and
so the last ones we've had were a kind
of going into the
2017 uh bull run
uh b coming out of the 2018 bear market
heading into the mini 2019 uh bull
market when we ran up to like 14k
and then also heading into late last
year before the you know before we broke
all-time highs and got into the real
mania phase of of the early bull market
um and we just got another one like two
or three weeks ago so to me this is
illustrating in a broader sense we're in
this uh you know uh
state of state of supply shock and i
suspect like the full effects of this
aren't you know fully priced in yet
and then when you look at supply shock
ratios uh across the other two it seems
like exact same thing it's just this is
completely being ignored but maybe not
ignored but uh is definitely underpriced
in the market in terms of how bullish it
is
yeah like well just like as a side thing
i suspect like as more people look at
this stuff um just by because of
information asymmetry like the the
signal of it may go away over time as
more people look at this stuff but yeah
um we've had this bull div between the
supply ratios so we have on the screen
uh the liquid supply shock ratio just
tracking the movement of coins basically
from weak to strong hands um the highly
liquid ratio which is tracking the
movement of coins from highly liquid to
liquid
and so that tends to
be a bit more reactive tends to get
squeezed but it can also sometimes be a
leading indicator like if you'll see um
like right above where it says august
30th you'll see like highly liquid
supply started moving up before uh the
liquid supply shock ratio so sometimes
it can it can be a leading indicator so
i like to look at that as well um and
then also the the exchange supply shock
ratio and this is just comparing the
amount of coins that are available
available to be bought on exchanges um
relative to overall circulating supply
and so yeah like earlier this week we
got a bullish impulse in that
posted out of my twitter and then at the
same time we had price kind of going
sideways bearish and so um yeah i think
we're starting to see some resolution of
uh you know that supply shock um also or
impulse whatever you want to call it um
also it's interesting because this comes
in confluence with
a volatility squeeze that we've entered
about five days ago
and like just based off of the
historical time frames that they usually
resolve um that that looks likely to
resolve in the next week while at the
same time i kind of have a similar time
frame with the effects of this impulse
so
um you know the volatility squeeze is
just saying we'll have a big move but
when you look at this i think this kind
of gives some clues as to perhaps the
directionality of that breakout
got it when we look at the exchanges
this is probably my favorite thing to
look at is just seeing that the exchange
flows are going one way and it's not on
to the exchanges it's off the exchange
explain this
yeah so we have four charts here so in
the top left you'll see the balance on
exchanges and then it's the stacked
version so you just see like each
individual exchange is a different color
um the top right is the exchange net
position change so this is looking at
the 30-day difference between you know
what are exchange balances today what
are exchange balances 30 days ago and so
that's useful because you know it can
get noisy i would i don't recommend
anybody to look at this stuff intraday
um and then also you know like
day in day out it can get a little noisy
too but when you start to see a trend on
the on the net position change which is
you know the 30-day change as we just
said you can you can be a bit more
confident in that trend because it's a
broader trend that's being sustained
and then on the bottom we have
coinbase balance and then on the bottom
right um you'll see binance's balance
and so there's this interesting kind of
dynamic here where you started to see
buyers show back up on coinbase while at
the same time coins have been moving
back on to binance um excuse me and so
to me this kind of illustrates twofold
first of all
you know one thesis could be you have
buying in the east selling in the west
i'm sorry the revolts of the reverse you
have buying in the west selling in the
east or also it could just illustrate
the fact that there's demand for the
speculative products that binance offers
got it if we move ahead to the
short-term holders and long-term holder
ratio uh what are you seeing in this it
seems to be trending upwards
yeah so this this is comparing um the
amount of supply that long-term holders
possess um in comparison to the amount
of spy that short-term holders possess
and so what you see is you kind of get
this like zone where um very similar to
a liquid supply you get this zone where
you have a supply shock effect on the
market
and when you look at this you'll see at
the bottom i put in these little
brackets and the reason i did that was
to illustrate the difference between now
and late 2017 because when i show a lot
of people this chart they say oh well
long-term holders buy into the into the
bear market why why is this a bullish
thing
and that's true but when you look at the
rate of change um in terms of um where
the where this bottomed out and how fast
it recovered to get into that zone of
supply shock it's not even close right
um and then also where you look at the
base that it grew off of it's much
higher than the base that grew off of in
late 2017
and so this is just another way of
looking at once again we're getting this
kind of uh lockup of supply in the
market um and so yeah over the next
month or two i suspect we would probably
get to that top part of that green
little highlighted range
got it and so we're going to pull up the
the chart here that you're talking about
basically what you're saying here is um
the
brackets of the supply shock ratio uh
chart it really shows that there is like
a time period of growth uh yeah this one
right here there's like a time period of
growth on the brackets and then that
shows this like massive move upward and
what you're talking about is this green
highlighted area is really the area that
you're looking at and it looks like
we're about to enter back into there
yeah exactly yep
got it okay um and then let's look at
the spent output age bands i know you've
been talking about this for a while and
it seems to uh to be confirming a lot of
the same stuff
yeah so what we'll be looking for here
is like are long-term holders who set
the floor are they starting to take exit
liquidity um and so when you look back
at late 2017 into early 2018 when you
had the dead cat bounce up to whatever
17k
you saw they spent outputs from six
months and older uh that went all the
way up to like 45 percent so you had
this basic basically all the long-term
holders jumped ship and took this took
the opportunity to to take their profits
and get out of the market um because
they had no confidence that that we're
going to see continuation
got it and so right now what we've seen
is just one kind of what's what appears
to be just a one-off spike about two
weeks ago actually has been declining
since then but not seeing anything that
resembles that kind of you know jump
ship uh abandon ship behavior from these
long term holders um it doesn't look
like they're taking exit liquidity it
looks like they're just holding strong
and then the last thing uh is minor
profitability uh miners seem to be real
excited
right now more so than they were you
know back in q1 maybe what are you
saying with minor profitability
yeah so you'll see like three different
colored lines um the purple bluish
whatever you want to call it mine that
that's hash
the orange line is is minor balances and
then the green line is minor
profitability so it's just looking at
revenue per hash
and so you get this dynamic kind of this
inverse correlation between as as hash
rate comes back on um profitability so
revenue per hash goes down so you've
seen hash slowly come back on the
network you know still far from where it
was uh you know peak earlier this year
um but it is slowly coming back on and
at the same time that means that you
know revenue per hash after we just had
this difficulty adjustment last week is
starting to trend down
and then at the same time you're
starting to see miners trim their
holdings just a little bit not anything
that's going to have any kind of you
know serious impact on the market
they've sold about 1 700 coins
in the last 10 days so i know just
something to keep an eye on but not you
know this isn't anything that's that's
uh you know anything to be concerned
about uh miners sold into the early bull
run uh in february earlier this year as
well you know it's to be expected that
they're going to take some profits on a
move up and this selling pressure isn't
anything that's gonna you know cause
some major downdraw in the market but i
do think it's just interesting to follow
what miners are doing
for the last couple of days you've been
tweeting about a move back to 50 000 and
you essentially have identified that as
like one key area um and it appears that
we've overtaken the 50k
uh
where do you expect us to go from here
and how are you thinking about um you
know 50 000 in the importance moving
forward
yeah so like when we looked at the
on-chain volume earlier what you'll see
is like there's a gap between 50k and
54k um so i wouldn't be surprised if we
if we see a move there in the coming
days um i'm also keeping an eye on
funding though so like
if open interest starts to starts to
spike in comparison to market cap and
you start to see like funding skyrocket
then perhaps we'll get some short-term
pullback but at the same time these
broader supply metrics are showing that
you know i
i have very strong confidence that we're
gonna see continuation over the coming
weeks
um you know but we'll have to keep an
eye on the derivative stuff but yeah i'd
be looking from an on-chain perspective
um for 54k um and then i think from a
technical perspective the the last real
resistance is like 58 to 60k um you know
once once we break that it's pretty much
blue skies so yeah those are i guess
kind of some of the levels i'd be
watching is it fair to say that you're a
19 year old kid who dropped out of
college for a semester because you're
anticipating the bitcoin bull run being
absolutely breathtaking the rest of this
year
yeah definitely that that had a lot to
do with my thought process it's like
i think i think you know if we were in a
bear market i may have not made that
decision right but i think like i'm
gonna be very busy over the coming
months and so you know for now i think
like just taking a break from school is
probably the the best choice at least in
the me and you know in the midterm but
yeah i think we're going to have a wild
q4 just based off of
um you know when you look at this data
in combination like of you know with
what i kind of hear anecdotally from
some you know some people with many more
connections than myself um it seems like
both of those are kind of aligning to
you know there's some uh perhaps big
buyers that that came in you know down
and over the last couple months um and
you know i i think we're gonna probably
see uh some interesting announcements
towards the end of the year but we'll
see what happens and as that happens
through the end of q4 uh everything that
we're seeing on chain right now the
reason why uh you think that you're a
lot of your time's gonna be focused here
is just that you know we continue to
move significantly upwards because
there's so many people holding on to
bitcoin with strong hands and as that
new demand comes in the price has to
accelerate rapidly to kind of
accommodate everyone
yeah exactly and like one chart like we
skipped over but if you look at the
broader trend of a liquid supply um the
liquid supply shock ratio what you see
is that we've been in this kind of like
descending channel for all of bitcoin's
history um and then after covet of last
year we actually broke above that and
we're kind of just free floating uh way
above this this channel so
to me what that's young is like the
broader huddling behavior is is unlike
dare i say this time is different um
it's unlike anything from any previous
uh bull run that we've been in um so
yeah like you're seeing really strong um
you know
buying and holding from from these new
market participants like also really
strong maturation of coins so like when
you look at like the realized cap huddle
waves you see the market participants
that came in over the last six months or
the last year they're starting to those
coins are starting to age um which which
is a good sign once again that like
people are coming in buying and holding
um you know it seems like the whole
narrative about you know people just
buying you know bitcoin with the
long-term uh you know
uh thesis on on how it's going to be
maybe you know an inflation hedge or
whatever it may be um i think the data
to an extent does reflect that
got it joe john you guys got any
questions uh i'll go first will you're a
legend uh congrats on on taking uh
making the decision to take a semester
off i think you're making a right
decision uh i think we're gonna see some
interesting price action like you said
and you will be very busy with that said
uh
what worries you like right like a lot
of this data looks great everything
we're hearing sounds great is there
anything that you're watching and you're
just uh you know keeping an eye on for
the bear case and you're and protecting
the downside a little bit
yeah for sure
um you know first of all it would be
like are these long-term holders like
kind of what we touched on are they
taking exit liquidity that's kind of the
last real like bear case in my mind um
also you can make an argument that
because uh like transactional activity
is low that that's somewhat of a bearish
thing but i kind of see both ways
because i also think that um
the the fact that there's no you know
the mempool is freed up it's it's kind
of showing that there's no like
speculative mania in the market right
now it's just you know experienced mark
participants um you also see that in in
like i'm laughing because i know i'm
like turning this into a bullish thing
but you also see like um you know a
large portion of volume is from from
larger marked participants so like the
amount of value transacted is mostly
large transactions so yeah i think like
there's a lot of speculation out of the
market but um yeah some people some
people would would see that as a bearish
thing that there's not a lot of you know
monetary value flowing through the
network um and also it doesn't look like
there's like really strong um demand to
to use the network right now when you
look at like the mempool um or like
number of transactions and stuff but
yeah like some people say that you know
that's just a reflection there's no
speculation in the market um you know
you have like transaction batching
that's now um used by coinbase although
i don't know to what extent that that's
the case but yeah
i i think you can make an argument there
that's that that's potentially a bearish
thing john
yeah well what's up congratulations on
uh leaving school big step i wish you
nothing but the best um
my question is on resistance levels and
like whales and other big players in the
space taking profits right so what is
what is the next resistance level if we
get past and when we get past 50k and
then uh at what point do you see kind of
people taking profits or is it just hey
they're gonna take profits the whole way
up and maybe when we get to 100k you'll
see like a bigger drawdown
yeah i think like you know
when it comes to when it comes to like
price discovery it's really hard to to
guess where price is going to take a
pause you know i think well first of all
before
you know theoretically we get to
all-time highs i think um the the
trillion dollar threshold which is right
on like 53 54k it's at like 53 200 um
that that's probably going to offer some
resistance and that kind of aligns with
unchained volume too so i think that may
give us like some short-term trouble um
but i don't think it'll be a you know
crazy resistance level um but then the
last kind of final boss is like 58 to
60k i guess you could say um but yeah
above that like if we if we were to get
into price discovery
i mean all you can really look at is
like like fibonacci retracement levels
or also just like psychological levels
you know bitcoin like almost any other
asset that um you know uh you know
reacts really really strongly to
different psychological levels like 50k
right or 60k 70k these round numbers um
so yeah like i don't know
the that'll be the only
that's the only way i could i don't know
kind of estimate where um you know
perhaps we'll take a breather but i
don't know you know keep in mind like
we're going to have corrections along
the way like i mean i'm bullish over the
coming months but that does not mean
we're not going to have you know 15 20
corrections along the way you know
well
if you had to rate your bullishness
right now one to ten ten being
the bowl of bowls one being uh not so
hot
where are you putting yourself
i i think we're cooking up like eight
and a half nine
that was a big number there
all right
uh you want to change the time frame too
if we're talking like the next couple
weeks yeah like short time i don't know
like yeah it's hard to do this
through the end of the year eight and a
half nine that's pretty good man that's
pretty good uh all right last uh last
question any changes to your end of year
uh thoughts yet or you still think we're
going you know 100k plus uh before the
end of the year nothing changed there
i'm sticking to my little uh the little
rainbow price model that i showed you
like a couple weeks ago i think um if we
can get above this
i call it the the delta top mean which
is the difference between um the
historical model that's time the tops in
the historical model that's 10 to bottom
um that's right around 5860k which is in
confluence with like that final boss in
terms of ta levels um if we can get
above that which served as resistance in
the 2017 get dead cat i think that's
like full confirmation we're back in the
bull market and so if we can break above
that then i would be targeting uh the
next
step up in the model um and that's i
think right around uh well it's like 90
96k but by you know by the time we
theoretically reach it'll be above 100.
so yeah that would be like my next
target and then if we broke above that
i'd be targeting the final or the top
model which
right now is that like 180k
that sounds like a good number to me
i tend to think that uh you're gonna be
more right than wrong but let's uh let's
see what happens um all right man where
where can we send people to follow you
on twitter let me drop your uh twitter
handle right now into uh into the
comments and uh
where can they subscribe to the email
what do you think of the new header by
the way i think it's pretty dope
i it feels like a little like futuristic
there what was that yeah is that japan
yeah i just looked up like tokyo neon
lights i just thought it looked cool
hey man listen you you uh you drop out
or take a semester off next thing i know
you're gonna be on in asia uh with
everyone in korea like trading a bunch
of bitcoin like hour by hour
yeah right i i definitely i'd like to
travel this whole another shot
conversation we can have but i want to
travel so i got to get some some
recommendations from you guys oh man you
ain't going back to school dawg
it's over listen tell the teachers
goodbye tell him hey listen i'm gonna
take the semester off but maybe i'll
never see you again so let me just say
bye either way
[Music]
yeah
i'm on twitter at uh w clementi iii and
then the link to the newsletters in my
in my bio as well
he doesn't want to say anything because
his mom probably watches this or his dad
and they're going to be like hey he
promised he was going to go back
yeah i did
he's definitely going back i promise i
promise i'm on the way out you should
tell them to sign up for your newsletter
so you know that you're like listen
you're teaching 60 40 portfolios i'm
teaching about the future why don't you
uh sign up for the newsletter me get
educated yeah
all right man listen thank you very much
for doing this i think that uh uh you
you've been all over this supply squeeze
and uh so far i've been very right so uh
i think just keep at it the the charts
look great doing a great job people are
enjoying it so uh we're going to uh
we're gonna do it again next week any uh
any last words and any college party
plans this weekend anything we should
know
i can't say too much but you know it's
memorial day monday so
it's memorial day every weekend there's
something well every weekend it's it's
well there's people at uc
it's labor day they'll party for like
columbus day but yeah they'll party for
anybody so you're so focused on the
plans you forgot that it's labor day and
not memorial day but oh look at that
the
well summer's just starting he's done
with school uh what do your friends
think by the way have you uh have you
taken the semester off they even care
no i mean yeah they think it's cool like
i don't know a lot of them don't really
know what to make of it but you know i
mean like dude to be honest like half
people don't even know what i do so like
my parents don't even still know what i
do
but they just know i do stuff with
bitcoin they just
they just think it's cool i don't know
i don't talk about it too much because
like if i start talking about it with
them they'll just like fall asleep so
they see everything growing and they're
like all right it all looks good
yeah
pretty much
it's all right man you're doing a great
job keep it up uh i i i think you made a
good decision here we'll uh we'll see
will's mom will's dad was a great kid
you should definitely be proud of your
son he's gonna go back to college when
uh when bitcoin goes to zero uh and uh
and we'll talk to you next week buddy
all right you guys take it easy have a
great weekend you too later
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]